ma fille diane appelé pour me dire
qu'elle n'a pas le temps de m'appeler
bah c'est aujourd'hui je t'appelle
regarde
[Musique]
non mais j'aurais nous l avons fait les
jours aujourd'hui elle a fait sa
maman bah oui qui me tue que ce soit oh
merde j'ai dû faire une fausse manip
magnifique chrono elle nos enfants c'est
pas sûr qu'ils soient là
commence à faire sérieusement chier et
de petit con nos enfants nos calculs
plus on va les fermes calculé
allez c'est parti coucou série on a
gagné avec papa beaucoup d'argent à tous
bisous bisous
pour bien oui allez combien
18 mai
[Musique]
il faut consacrer 10 rue 89 le rouler la
minute et la portière
c'est bon j'ai déjà marchand et moi je
leur mette plein golfe
ont leur manque je voudrais rhabiller ma
fille pour lisait
comme suit titien ils sont par mon porte
monnaie non m aux enfants sont là pour
le réveillon
et c'était fait je viens de faire une
tache sur ma chemise comment je fais
[Musique]
tu as une paire de ciseaux qui découpe
autant de la tâche et normalement il
devrait plus avoir de tâches
[Musique]